ben Carson referred to black slaves as
immigrants which was really weird to
people who know anything at all about
the difference between immigrants and
slaves you might recall that former
presidential candidate ben Carson was
appointed and confirmed to be Donald
Trump Secretary of Housing and Urban
Development and it didn't make sense
then and it doesn't make sense now why
Carson is secretary of HUD my one
thought at the time was well Carson's
black and Trump associates the word
urban with black people as we saw during
the campaign so we heard Oh Urban
Development I know a black guy this
neurosurgeon and inspirational speaker
ben Carson let's put him in charge of
HUD anyway he now is secretary of HUD
and yesterday he addressed the staff of
the Department of Housing and Urban
Development and he gave a bogus speech
devoid of all meaning but one weird
thing that happened is he referred to
black slaves brought to the US against
their will and forced to work for
nothing and many of them being raped as
immigrants which was odd to say the
least here's the video a land of dreams
and opportunity there were other
immigrants who came here in the bottom
of slave ships worked even longer even
harder for less but they too had a dream
that one day their son daughters
grandsons granddaughters great-grandson
great granddaughters might pursue
prosperity and happiness and visit land
yet those immigrants who came in slave
ships who worked harder for less you
mean worked for nothing after being
kidnapped right their dream was they
wouldn't have been taken by force as
slaves they weren't working hard for a
better life they were working as hard as
necessary to avoid getting whipped or
raped by some white guy the best
explanation for this that I've heard of
so far or that I've been able to come up
with I guess is that he was on ambien
and we know that he all he often seems
kind of like either a hypnotherapist or
like he's on ambien and he doesn't
recall saying any of this unfortunately
that doesn't appear to be the case a
very very odd situation and if you're
kidnapped and forced to work under
threat of death and rape are you really
an immigrant
working for a better life that he just
insane no you absolutely aren't I really
just think it's a poor choice of words
that's my take on it I don't think there
was any malice behind what he said it's
ignorance more than Alice to me right
now you're talking about people who were
stolen and treated like animals there
there there that's yet another story of
immigration because the word immigrants
seems to imply that you're coming over
voluntarily and that you're looking for
a better life yeah and for the 200-plus
years that we had slavery in this
country and in the colonies that
certainly was not the case about the
experience by no means and CNN brought
on black Trump supporter Paris Denard to
defend Carson and he did by trying to
loop in martin luther king such
pandering check this out and what if
you're watching look at the expression
on Anderson Cooper's face and on Angela
rise face when Paris denard tries to
bring up Martin Luther King parish nard
and Angela rye Paris as you know there's
obviously got a lot of pick up a lot of
controversy of kind of went viral do you
think as much ado about nothing look I
think that secretary Carson may have
chosen to use the words that might have
been the best word are you saying
immigration but I don't think anybody
should take his comments during this
speech as him not understanding the
difference between voluntary immigration
involuntary servitude albert was
reminded of a quote from dr. Desmond
attributes of dr. King's which says we
may have all come on different ships but
were in the same boat now nobody
insinuates that dr. King was either
belittling the way or the manner by
which African Americans came to this
country our Africans came to this
country and I don't think we should do
the same with dr. Carson what that quote
has nothing to do with what ben Carson
said that's what we call a straw man
argument and there's another defense
I've heard which is Oh Carson was just
speaking extemporaneously that's not
really a defense at some point you have
to be accountable for your words at
least this time para cenar didn't just
call CNN fake news and that was his
argument yeah last clip we had of Paris
denard Don Lemon shut down his show
because Paris dehart insisted that the
segment he was participating in was an
example of fake news